le mardi noir c'est l'intitulé de la
mobilisation des élèves du lycée joseph
zobel à rivière salée
c'est l'effet papillon ils répondent à
l'appel des lycéens de métropole
déterminé depuis quelques jours a
bousculé le gouvernement pour qu'il
annule toutes les nouvelles réformes qui
les pénalisent fortement nous en tant
que quand tu y es d'habitants
d'outre-mer on est vraiment à laisser
sur le côté parce que la réforme de par
pur sucre pas creuser vraiment les
inégalités entre l'hexagone et l'autre
mère il ya des cas concrets comme la
major du bac de polynésie qui a été
refusé avec 21 28 pts être 7 de moyenne
et elle a été refusée dans des écoles
les écolos a été postulé à paris donc
c'est pas normal c'est un mouvement que
les lycéens ne compte pas lâcher sans
résultat ils veulent fédérer tous les
établissements pour être mieux entendu
les élèves du lycée joseph zobel insiste
sur le côté pacifique de leur démarche
et c'est dans cet esprit qu'ils veulent
aller à la rencontre du recteur
d'académie
dans quelques jours on est vraiment là
pour monter un mouvement généralisé
aujourd'hui c'était au lycée joseph
zobel au lycée des marcs à demain je
l'espère ce sera les autres lycées qui
viendront nous rejoindre
et je l'espère que le recteur pourra
nous aussi nous entendent donc vraiment
nous sommes là pour la discussion
me sembla pour avancer les lycéens ont
été reçus ce matin par le proviseur ils
sont mobilisés jusqu'à ce vendredi 14
mai s'ils n'obtiennent pas satisfaction
du lycéen de rivière-salée à neuf un
durcissement dès la semaine prochaine